New video tonight of embattled
Republican Congressman George Santos
under fire
for telling a long list of lies
to voters.
Dodging questions from our Manu
Raju, specifically refusing to say why
among many other lies,
he falsely claimed to be a member
of the Baruch College volleyball team.
Here's Santos, his response.
Why did you lie
about being on a volleyball
you're like American people.
When you stop
reporting, I'll start to show
where you actually were on a volleyball
team.
Is that right?
In college, Baruch College.
Is that true?
This is Santos
ex-boyfriend is speaking
to OUTFRONT
for his first television interview
and an OUTFRONT exclusive.
Pedro Vilarva
shared this photo with us of him
celebrating Christmas with Santos
and other loved ones in 2014.
He told me that Santos went by the name
Anthony Devolder when they dated.
They lived together for about a year.
And the Lava says
he repeatedly turned down
Santos proposals to get engaged
Pedro joins me now from Brazil.
And Pedro,
I very much appreciate your time
and I know
that you're
deciding to speak out
was a very careful decision
Does this George Santos,
the one that we are now all seeing, sound
like the man that you dated
and lived with?
No.
Not at all.
Completely different person.
How so?
It's just
at the beginning of the relationship.
It was fine.
He was so sweet, caring
He actually showed
that he actually cared, you know?
But later on,
like when I started finding out the lies,
I thought that was it.
That it was my phone.
The ones that he stole, that
you ponded that I believe
the jewelry as well from from our friend
that used to live with us.
And so,
like the tickets to Hawaii that he had
purchased for us to
go where he was planning
to be
proposing for the third time as well.
Well, the engagement never happened.
Nothing like that.
I know you say Santos
repeatedly asked you to get engaged
before you broke up,
and he appears, Pedro,
to reference you
in an Instagram post
that you shared with us from 2015
he writes,
This is my family that I managed to
screw up.
I will not give up.
I will fight till the end.
I love you, PvE.
I miss you now.
Pedro, you were 18
and Santos was 26 when you met him.
When did you know
that you couldn't trust him?
Towards the end of the relationship.
It was more started.
Like I started finding out
about the lights in December
and then it went on till February.
And then
that's when I broke up with them.
And then I went on my way.
But then later on,
like we still had contact with each other
because he didn't like,
I found out about the lies,
but we still kept
in contact with each other
just being like, Oh, how are you?
How's your mom and stuff?
Because when I found out
that she was sick, I still cared for her.
And then I went to visit her
a couple of times later on.
But then
when I found out about the other stuff,
I was like, What a psycho
You know,
I want to share a picture of you
that you shared
with us of you and his mother.
You say you were close.
And besides, you know,
he said she's was a survivor of the nine
11 terror attacks, right? She was.
He also claims
she was an executive at Citigroup.
She was a part of many of his lies there.
There you are with her.
This is a picture you shared with us.
Did did she ever discuss
these these lives with you?
Did she know any of this?
Oh, I never
know. Nine 11? No.
Citigroup, nothing like that
from when I was with them.
I never saw her going to work
at Citigroup. Or anything.
And they never mentioned anything
about nine 11,
even because I was born on nine 11.
And if I see if they knew that
I was born in nine 11,
I think they were going to reference that
and say something about it,
but never heard anything about it.
I want to play Jorge Santos
what we've all now heard
Pedro explaining
who he is
in his own words over the years.
My grandparents survived the Holocaust.
I'm a Latino, too.
My mom was a nine elevenths survivor.
They sent me to a good prep school, so
and which was harassment.
Prep in the Bronx.
I actually went to school on
on a volleyball scholarship.
And when I was in Peru,
we were the number one volleyball.
But I put myself through college
and got an MBA from
NYU and also founded my own
nonprofit organization.
Prior to running, I decided to close it.
It was an animal rescue
We had a great organization.
We were able to save animals, dogs,
cats, horses.
I've lived an honest life.
I've never been accused, sued of anything
bad doing.
I do want to
note, of course,
he was charged with embezzlement.
So he has obviously been
accused of bad doing.
But you know, Pedro,
the point is
some of these lies were so minor
and yet so specific.
I mean, the volleyball one. Right.
Not just saying that
he played volleyball,
but he had a scholarship
that he slayed teams
from Harvard and Yale
that he was the smallest player
on the team, that he needed
to get two knee replacements.
I mean, you know,
he went deep with the lies.
Why does he do this?
I think he was I don't know.
I think he's just out of his mind.
And one lie led to the other.
And now this.
Everybody found out.
Like they're finding out
like the little stuff as well.
I just think
he should now be in Congress.
And one.
Oh, my God.
It was so many things that I found out
afterwards as well.
Things that I did not know
because I still believe that
he actually went to college.
Like like he used to say
I already knew about the Citigroup.
They he said that he used to work in
like those investments.
And so so I already knew that
those were lies
because I never saw him working actually.
But then
the other stuff,
like the stuff about the part
he actually did used to say
about the organization,
about football as well,
that he used to do like
he there was another person.
They also had a pet organization,
so they used to have like a little
picking fights with each other as also
But then I never saw
anything going towards there like
charity stuff when we were together.
He never used to do anything.
So for his dad.
So it was so it's.
You know, what do you say?
Are you surprised he's
now a member of Congress?
That
that was that was an ambition that he had
always what he always looked for
was fame and power.
That's all the all he cared about.
And he got it.
He got the thing
of the lies
and he got the power
that he's in Congress now.
But it's a he shouldn't be there.
Well, the story has gotten so big, right?
Everyone everyone
is paying attention to it.
You know,
he's being spoofed by late
night shows and other comedians.
Here's a clip from this
weekend's Saturday Night Live.
Don't know if you saw it,
but I'll play it for you, Peter.
You lied about your mom dying in nine 11.
I think I said seven 11.
No, you know,
you even lied about being Jewish.
No, I said I was Jewish.
Jewish people need to know who you are.
Okay, well,
I am George
Santo's mischievous older sister.
Nasty.
I graduated on a volleyball scholarship
from Baraka tomorrow night.
University
I see you laughing.
People are laughing.
But obviously, you know,
this is serious stuff.
I mean,
do you think that he'll ever resign?
I don't think so.
His ego's too is too big.
Isn't too high.
He's not going to resign
if they don't find out
something to get him off
he's not going to do it, that's for sure.
All right.
Well, Pedro, I appreciate your time.
Thank you very, very much.
I appreciate your time as well.
Thank you so much.